a notorious Mexican kingpin named El
Chapo stages an elaborate escape from a
maximum security prison and threatens
the life of one of our least favorite
reality stars thank you
you may have heard about el chapo guzman
recently and wondered who is the sky I'm
an East fair-weather and I'm here to
fill you in on the infamous El Chapo and
all about this insane story this is
hashtag newspeople El Chapo is like the
Houdini of drug dealers he's been called
the king of tunnels and has evaded
authorities in numerous times with the
help of underground corridors
he's even escaped from maximum-security
prison twice the first time was in 2001
by hiding in a laundry cart that was
wheeled out by the prison security guard
the whole thing was planned through
bribes and intimidation and the 2.5
million dollar escape involves up to 78
accomplices this isn't a movie but if it
was it would have a killer lineup he was
captured again in 2014 and escaped again
recently this time the king of tunnels
did what he does best and escaped
through a narrow tunnel cut into a
shower stall which led to a large
elaborate mile long passageway complete
with ventilation and lighting and Oh get
this he rode away in the tunnel on a
motorcycle
climb aside that's the most badass way
to escape just busting out on a
motorcycle popping some wheelies down a
tunnel probably got a hot chick on his
way out we'll just like will slow Blade
II that's crazy so now I'll chop I was
out there that's right he's among us
he's running free
and he's tweeting yeah yeah I know you
heard me he's on Twitter this is a true
21st century criminal recent Twitter
highlights include there's no jail for
such a big [ __ ] and life takes many
turns one day you're in the hole and the
next day you're on top he also had the
balls to tweet the President of Mexico
saying don't call me a delinquent
because I give people work unlike your
current government I've heard he did
follow this guy but there's more Donald
Trump presidential very hopeful recently
called Guzman out when accusing the
Mexican government is sending rapists
drug runners and other criminals to the
US he went on a told you so Twitter
rampage aimed at El Chapo he said
Mexico's biggest drug lord escapes from
jail
unbelievable corruption and USA is
paying the price I told you so can you
envision Jeb Bush or Hillary Clinton
negotiating with El Chapo Trump however
would kick his ass first of all Trump
speaking in third person please don't
this time Trump messed with the wrong
guy El Chapo's Twitter responded in a
soft understanding way keep poking
around I don't make you eat your words
in YT at real Donald Trump oh I'm afraid
I'm gonna unfollow these are the point
out but in the end there is no end
el chapo is a modern-day villain we need
to remember that this is a real person
who is hurting people and the country of
Mexico through the criminal drug trade
so let's not root for this guy no matter
how cool is escape attempts are or how
tough his tweets are ok I'm officially
getting off my soapbox oh yeah you're
sure now please subscribe to new media
rockstars for more explanations of other
crazy news stories in the comments let
me know what you think about this story
what do you think about Donald Trump and
his ability to be such a dumbass I'll be
responding to your comments I'm gonna be
reading
home while eating a bowl of cereal with
lactose free milk because I'm lactose
intolerant you guys let me know I can't
wait to hear from you I'm Annie East
Fairweather and I'm gonna go hide from
El Chapo in my car which is where I live
eating in El Charro by I can't wait for
in churro honestly that's the only
reason you go to Disney
it's worth the money and it's the best
throw if you get a TRO at any other
place it's not as good like SeaWorld
used to have good Charles and I was a
kid but not